bonjour nicolas bonjour ma vie alors
votre coup de gueule ce matin nicolas ce
n'est pas exclusivement consacrée à la
crise sanitaire et aux passes vaccinale
tiens donc non on change un peu de sujet
parce que de penipe tout ça et oui ce
matin je ne vous parlerai pas des mains
tendues du dresseur de couleuvres en la
personne de jean michel blanquer que
certains au gouvernement appelle jean
michel à peu près je ne parlerai pas non
plus du duo trajet quand revers en
écosse textes des laurel et hardy ducobu
qui avait d'ailleurs pas sanitaire
magique sautonne très chers amis de
faire péter les records de contamination
alors qu'il nous avait vendu le
contraire et je ne ferai pas la promo de
la panique orchestrée autour du au
micron qui met le pays dans une grosse
pagaille je ne parlerai pas non plus
cette surprenante rencontre entre gérald
darmanin et laurent fabius président du
conseil constitutionnel pourrait vous
évoquez je cite de nouvelles mesures
d'organisation qui apparaît très
nécessaire par la crise sanitaire afin
de garantir le bon déroulement de
l'action présidentielle fin de citation
même si ce truc ça sent l'entourloupe a
plané ce matin par contre nous allons
revenir sur les voeux la thèse à la
presse des manuels premier qui nous a
fait le panégyrique de la presse
indépendante plurielle diverses libre
innovantes objective et responsable il a
d'ailleurs évoqué en techno langage des
macros nist l'espace informationnel
alors ne cherchez pas dans le petit
robert chers amis car cela ne veut
absolument rien dire c'est comme vous
savez le référent bondissant pour parler
d'un ballon c'est ridicule mais ça fait
cool chez les communicants de l'élysée
d'ailleurs bise à eux mais pour revenir
à ses voeux il a été surtout question de
la définition de la presse acceptable et
docile et donc respectable magali alors
mais quel était donc l'objet des voeux
de la presse des manuels macron cette
année est bien la glisse et des temps de
quelle presse on parle car j'ai eu la
fâcheuse impression qu emmanuel macron
s'est adressée essentiellement aux
organes de l'anpans c'est accepter aux
producteurs d'idées en deux gammes aux
scream de la dépêche afp ainsi qu'aux
father de sujet unique et monochrome il
s'est adressé à cette presse qui selon
lui a eu notamment une action civique en
publiant il ya quelques mois les
absurdes rappelez-vous auto attestation
à découper soi même alors je me suis dit
qu'on aurait pu faire ça avec des
tickets de loto ou des masques ffp2 à
déchirer sur la maine entre les mots
croisés et la météo mais pas un mot par
exemple sur les rares journalistes qui
ont posé la question du contenu des
contrats entre les labos pharmaceutiques
et l'union européenne où les rares
articles évoquant l'histoire de quelques
députés européens qui ont dénoncé ces
contrats et fuste j'ai les mesures
répressives partout en europe on a eu le
coupé sur la liberté d'informer sur la
protection des journalistes sur le droit
des formations comme pilier de la
démocratie et patati et patata mais il
n'a pas été question bizarrement des
joints et de plusieurs rédactions qui
ont été entendus en 2019 rappelez-vous
par la dg ainsi devenu enquête sur
l'exportation d'armes par la france donc
finalement quand tu copies copie colle
un communiqué ministériel annick
hollande des gommettes tu as le droit
d'informer mais lorsque tu fais un peu
ton boulot chers amis pour faire vivre
la démocratie ça devienne de suite plus
délicat et si tu diffuse un reportage
choc obid et que tu mets comme source au
niveai véran là c'est le graal par
contre emmanuel macron a longuement
évoqué la question des thèses
complotistes du graff défèque news des
organes de presse étrangers qui
cherchent à déstabiliser l'unité de la
nation suivez mon regard l'artillerie
lourde a été deux sorties puis on nous a
sorti la mandoline pour nous parler de
l'exigence du débat démocratique de la
responsabilité et de la liberté des
journalistes de l'information éclairé et
du diktat de l'émotion alors moi je veux
pas paraître chaque fois et ce matin
mais j'ai la désagréable impression que
c'était un peu les voeux à la pensée
unique mais aussi une charge très
violente contre les médias tu totalement
indépendant qui tentent avec leurs
moyens de donner aux français un autre
son de cloche et qui refusent de
déverser lors de longues processions
médiatique des tonnes de chantilly sur
l'elysée magali vous estimez finalement
qu emmanuel macron ne s'est pas adressé
à l'ensemble de la profession des
journalistes certains n'avaient pas pu
entrer d'ailleurs exactement non plus
d'ailleurs chez bush alors comme il me
semble que emmanuel premier soit très
attaché au concept dessous citoyenneté
est ce que le journalisme trop
indépendante doit souffrir aussi de ne
plus avoir le droit d'être respectés
doigts qui souffrirent d'accusation
sournoise de fake news et de
désinformation l'outil se restreindre à
faire du bateau nage de dépêches afp at
on encore le droit dans ce pays de poser
des questions il cherchait à comprendre
sans se voir accuser de complotisme
alors moi je ne continue pour ma part je
continuerai à me lever à l'aube a
beaucoup travaillé a beaucoup lire à me
documenter à me poser des questions aux
jurés plus que jamais sur le terrain
sans a priori là où tout se passe et je
continuerai informer les français qui
ont éteint leur télé et couper leurs
radios depuis bien longtemps car le
journalisme vraiment indépendant et
honnête beau français le pluralisme des
voix qui semble être devenu le pire que
je pars d'un progressisme autoritaire
car la déontologie des médias
indépendants et dans la charte munich
encore faut-il avoir lu alors oui
souffrait encore une fois emmanuel
macron que tous les journalistes ne
soient pas vacciner que le sérum du
politiquement correct et de la
complaisance et jules renard écrivait je
cite le comble pour un journaliste c'est
d'être à l'article de sa mort eh bien
aujourd'hui c'est le journalisme de
déférence qui a même qui n'a n'est pas
loin magali merci merci pour ce coup de
gueule nicolas c'était l'édito politique
de la matinale sébastien merci beaucoup